all right it's 7 A.M in the morning
and this guy is screaming his brains out
going hey
what the heck is going on
you need to explain yourself what kind
of jeans are these this is from your
side
I know how much of a banshee you guys
are
a Banshee huh what's a banshee that's
someone that screams oh this is pink you
see
that looks nice
it's too hot are you gonna do your face
finally yeah
can you get away from me
your son is going crazy can you wait for
me please
is that beautiful or what that looks
like Vegas is above the clouds
oh really
someone must be on their period exactly
really do you still love me no not for
this week good night everybody what
about next week
I don't know it's a long shot do you
love him though always forever you're my
little angel baby oh my God that's so
sweet I do not love you because because
you do not love Papa oh because he's a
monkey you got my back
thank you man he knows what he's doing
he picks a mama too thank you mister
you're the best thank you
if you've been watching the Vlogs then
you know that my mom's been staying with
us for a few weeks now the part that I'm
sad about is because we're so busy
during the week we can't really take my
mom anywhere and my mom loves the
mountains So since today is the weekend
I'm gonna take my mom to the mountains
specifically Mount Charleston because
it's such a beautiful mountain ridge
here in Vegas and since it's cold we
might even find some snow it's gonna be
awesome so my mom got snow pants on this
guy is ready to rock and roll and mama's
always STEEZ the F out look at you
she's wearing my shoes I know that's
that's what I meant because in the
morning I saw you wearing those I'm like
those are steezy
did it
so we've actually never been here before
bros breakfast and lunch
we were just on our way and we were just
like you know what let's just do the
explore method which is one of our
favorite methods which is just drive in
the direction and then when we're like
on the main freeway like we know we
don't have to like take this freeway to
that fruit to that for you anymore then
we just look and we kind of eat
something in that area so we're still
pretty far we're not like uh we're
probably still a good 30 minutes out but
we're like halfway between where we live
and where that is so this is a
completely unfamiliar area so like let's
go explore and we found this spot called
Bros breakfast and lunch
so my mom is a hot cocoa Queen
and look at this one holy moly it's kind
of sexual are you gonna drink it yeah
thank you so much can you drink it tell
me if it's good
later later what are you doing right now
okay
women
foreign
okay we're arguing about what the hell a
macchiato is what do you think a
macchiato is uh so what I meant to say
is a mocha no no you said macchiato
you're a doubling down what's a
macchiato uh so macchiato I think is you
said it was hot cocoa and coffee no I
didn't I didn't say that I said it was
chocolate Okay chocolate obviously I
said it was upside down espresso she
called my bluff what's an upside down
espresso I don't know that's what I
think it is uh so I think a macchiato is
when it's like half
foam and then I think it's half espresso
you were a barista before I know I was
but that was like how many years ago 20
years you learn you don't but learn
oh it's the other way around so it's
kind of like a latte yeah but with like
minimal foam
yeah like a latte would have like a lot
of foam and stuff uh water I mean milk
yeah but it's yeah so it's a macchiato
that she likes I mean a mocha can you
just say the rice
oh my goodness yeah so my mom put some
of my coffee in there because that's
what she likes and then I get to
represent a bit of getting some hot
cocoa
that's a sick boat bro
[Music]
oh man the man of the hour
Turtle
Waffle and look at his eyes are glued to
it you see all the cinnamon and the
yummy sugar on there
[Music]
did you see his lips
his lips is gonna
make that a little that little red
tongue right there
okay the time has come where taika has
earned his waffle
and he's dancing okay
let's see dip it in there let me see the
good stuff you didn't even dip it
you don't need to huh yummy yummy
oh yeah steak and eggs protein I love
country potatoes and sourdough bread you
know what I'm saying
oh yeah
Belgian waffle doing the Asian thing
taking a picture you know what I'm
saying a whole year with a smiley face
we got a happy boy with a happy
breakfast and mama got that bomb ass BLT
that looks good I usually love breakfast
but seeing that sandwich actually looks
good I'll take a bite can I take one
bite
it's Texas toast bread they said oh is
that what it is
[Music]
a good toast
we have officially entered Mount
Charleston
because you can see the snow and now
there's a bunch of green trees and taika
is excited for the snow you excited for
the snow yes oh yeah baby okay I'm gonna
turn back around because I'm about to
throw up it's so windy it's so windy
why you keep saying that what again why
you keep saying
no throw up
because I feel like I'm a throw up so
beautiful it's beautiful
good job booties
[Music]
get all that snow over here
no it's fun huh be careful it might be
slippery okay
don't don't fall on your your pants
because they're just gonna get wet oh
yeah your pants are gonna get wet okay
because they're not snow pants
[Music]
do you like these crunchy sounds
it's too icy
have some snow in your hands yeah on my
fingers because
[Music]
you look more styling than functional
really yeah this is my my blanket coat I
love it nothing's pretty you look like
you're ready for a photo shoot oh really
you don't look like you're ready for a
snowball fight that's funny
are you ready for a snowball fight no do
not do that
don't land on it I'm like half scared
for my mom because she is 70 so I don't
want her to fall good thing Gio lent her
her snow shoes so she got good grip and
my mom's very mobile and active so
good job Mama yeah good job
oh yeah you're good whoa whoa whoa whoa
let's see if you can climb up mister
let's see
can you do it I believe in you oh you
keep sliding down
see if you could do it
go up there go go go oh no
Grandma found the easier one
okay let's see let's see if you could
get this one it's still slippery so be
careful
did you see all the snow
the ice
oh yeah oh someone's good okay okay whoa
whoa whoa did you fall on purpose dude
I think you fell on purpose
I take so much smaller on purpose are
you kidding me
are you kidding me what's up what the
are you kidding me
Cut From the Same Cloth
[Laughter]
see where Papa's going
okay here I come okay watch out monks
get out of the way
so here I come
ready yeah
yeah be careful
here I come
[Music]
back
your turn
[Music]
let me take a picture of you
here we go
wait what happened I told you your arm's
straight you're not doing arms straight
like Superman like this look look arms
Straight Like That
[Music]
okay you don't want to use it
[Music]
you guys don't want to use it
she's gonna eat it on purpose I knew it
[Music]
do this
arm straight put your arms right here
right here there you go okay arms
straight okay be careful grandma oh
that's good ready okay hold on tight
well that's our arm straight and your
arms I'm straight straight straight yeah
like that like that keep your arms
straight arm straight arms straight
they're not straight straight put your
arms Superman go yeah like that and then
hold it hold it
right right into the tree
good job did you panic a little bit a
little bit
top of me go
oh no
[Music]
[Music]
you guys are too heavy
yeah
okay that was actually pretty slow hey I
was trying to be safe okay I want to be
safe how about that
are you okay
my turn
be careful okay
you're not gonna do anything
[Music]
wow there's so many branches careful
we totally did not bring the right pants
Papa was like we'll just walk around I'm
like you're not gonna get in the Sun
goes no
okay
[Music]
yeah so I was like are you sure we're
not gonna get into stuff he's like no
we'll just probably walk around for 10
minutes and now look at them rolling
around in the damn snow I should have
known better
wow
okay Techo wanted to play hide and go
seek
[Music]
no no you gotta go back over there
[Music]
I know I counted to like 30.
one
two no no go all the way to Mom oh come
on okay I'm not gonna help you
please no
don't turn around
18 19 20. okay
[Music]
he's behind that tree
are you okay
that's ice that's ice
don't walk on top
right here
pajamas in the real life
are you kidding me
pajamas and hiking boots
mama how do you explain yourself pajamas
in public
what is this okay his clothes were wet
we weren't expecting to be out in the
public we were supposed to go straight
home that's true but he fell asleep but
he looks CUNY CUNY and comfy
whoa whoa whoa
did you know out of all of my sons
you're my favorite son
yeah I do have a lot of stuff yeah I got
like 30 cents look
did you know that what was the names
this guy looks so funny in his job
outside a restaurant this Javas and
hiking boots
and dance moves
thank you
pepperoni pizza it's so quiet me too
well let me see oh yeah right there
and then grandma got her vegetarian
pineapple and a Hawaiian oh yeah oh God
got the pizza the nice cheese nice and
thin you know what I'm saying with the
oils and the extra cheese on there oh
that soft little crust and I'm saying
here's yours
watch the cheese what the cheese
no
oh my God
you want the cheese to fall the cheese
the good stuff look at that
back home now and now it is time to get
to organizing because yesterday they
stopped by and installed our sick ass
garage doors I freaking love them
doesn't look dope you get all this light
coming in so before we need to come in
here it'd be all dark but now you get
all this light coming in and not only
does it look good but now I can see all
my stuff
like clearly whereas before I felt like
I needed not only my roof lights but
also a flashlight so it's time to clean
the garage
and what's also cool is when we first
moved in we're just trying to pack
things as fast as we could right so I
just by default was like I'm gonna put
the big shelves on that side Geo doesn't
like that because right when you come
out
there's all this stuff like in your way
so it kind of interrupts the flow and
she was like can you move it to the
other side I was like bro
I just put everything on this side
no but good thing we had to move this
whole Shelf
and that
is over there
so Jill was like Hey now it'd be a good
time to move and I'm like you know what
you're right so that is going to be the
goal of today which is to move this
Shelf
over on this side
and that would clear this whole Space
I just want to give you guys a taste of
what the garage door looks like on the
outside looks nice huh
so now with both of these down like this
it's gonna look so clean
and we have to put all the stuff away so
time to get to work
so far I was able to bring the Shelf in
and I moved everything on this shelf
just directly on there originally I was
going to unload the shelf and then drag
the Shelf over this way but then I was
like why would I do that stupid because
now I'm creating more clutter in the
middle when I'm taking it from here
putting it down here to put up there I'm
like why don't I just put here
to there
hey maybe you guys thought of it first
and you're like dude that's such a
[ __ ] third grade solution well I was
pretty proud of myself
so now we gotta move this Shelf
over to this side the only problem is
you'll see at the height of this Shelf
covers the voltage thing
and this part's open and this is our uh
sprinkler timer
so we were thinking we'll just leave
this open
use that to cover it and also have
access to it just sort of putting stuff
away be careful not to hit any of these
switches
but
just trying to figure out
what we're working with
and making it okay
I don't want to drag it so I'm gonna
grab Geo because taika is sleeping now
so I gotta can't be like
you know what I think
I think it's a success
[Music]
boom look at that
my ocds I don't even really care about
the function of this the first thing to
look for is is this flush
but cool that is flush looks like one
piece gotta push it in probably an
eighth of an inch but
now we have this
so it's perfectly pinned against the
wall
still can see where everything's at got
all the buttons
still open this is operable probably
will never use that socket
but bam there we go
and uh can't wait for them to install
our freaking fridge our fridge is so
dope it's two of those boxes it's like
the size of two fridges and one
but they're missing a part supply chain
issues I don't know so that thing is
still in here so that is always going to
be a pain in the ass because until they
move those things I can't even move our
little freezer remember a little
pandemic freezer that we got from back
in our La house
is that supposed to go next to the black
um tool case tool Shelf case
tools
Craftsman next to the black Craftsman
but uh
not just something I'm talking about
person
but anyways it's gonna go over there
okay
so time to continue
I wasn't able to sort everything like I
wanted
because it started getting dark as you
guys can see
but I was able to move everything from
the driveway
in here
besides the gym stuff
so I think not to split it up I think
it's gonna be today just move everything
in here
and then attack the gym tomorrow because
the gym actually has a lot of small
intricate like little bands screws all
that I think it's gonna take me four
hours to just organize just like a
handful of things
and then I'll get uh in here but at
least both of those shelves were on this
side this is packed looks nice behind
all this BS but you know I got all my
camping chairs here got my tent got my
dolly metal targets all kinds of packs
all those are backpacks and my backpack
fiend travel luggage I got all this
stuff in there
and uh
still got a lot to organize man and it's
just been a lot you know because uh if
you guys been following the Vlogs the
podcast all that stuff the last two
months been going through a lot so
barely got the house move
dad passes away
I'm trying to get seizures
still going back and forth to LA to
shoot all the time
for both JK and barbell so it's just a
lot of stuff so I'm moving an inch at a
time look I'm trying to force that inch
you know
and uh today was this is as much as I
can force had to break down this squat
rack shout outs to Griffin they make
really really good stuff
um but I had to retire the squat rack
because I just don't have enough space I
wish I did but um take it apart so let's
be a little bit more safe uh space
saving and then maybe um when we get the
backyard built I might have a space for
set up a little second squat station or
something
all right let's see
what Geo's progress looks like
because I think she's organizing her
closet
but she also has to watch taika
[Music]
is that what we're doing huh
just relaxing
laying around huh sure
while I'm out there working
sweating bowels off
you see this what I was able to move my
pile of clothes from here
yeah remember all that yeah what's over
here
oh awesome I'm glad you're able to just
focus on just yourself well I'm working
on the whole family's garage
that's what he did let's wear and though
you're here
and then I said Papa's gonna get mad so
I might as well just move it over here
and it looks like I did something right
no
it doesn't look I mean like I cleared it
good job
must be nice to have the luxury of
moving something over here moving over
there focusing on my clothes getting
creative while I'm out there
disassembling pieces of hard metal
in the cold air you know what I'm
talking about yeah but you like being
that man [ __ ] remember I am a man good
job I am a man
I am a man mister can I get your feet
off the drywall please you're gonna
scuff it up dude
thank you
no off the drywall please
no no wall
uh oh this guy has is this guy in
trouble
oh okay
so it looks like I'm not the only one
huh
oh wiping it's interesting that's wiping
the family's Furniture wow interesting
wipe in the family phone Tracy that
right now it's clean
Ed it very interesting okay
how excited he is
how excited he is
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
show everybody the reasons
oh thank you
thank you
this is nice he's almost 50 pounds now I
like a big kid yeah yeah yeah he's 30.
awesome he's dirty guys
now and then they can play okay
yeah okay this is really CUNY because
taika has been asking for Leia and Enzo
the whole day since he found out that uh
we were gonna watch Leon and also Aunt
and Christina can go to like a work
party he's been asking all morning for
now they put together digging through
toys
you guys find any cool toys
because all the toys are all packed
yeah it's a cool sound huh oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
hey that's a cool sound too
yup that's a music
[Music]
you think it's so funny huh Leia
if I could dance again go
okay you didn't see anything
okay
all right he did what
oh he's mid climbing he was trying to go
back at taika's old spot well good job
now you gotta find Leia where's Leia at
we found him right away I hear a Leia oh
man
hey I don't know if she knows how to
play this game right
[Music]
and then a very good job
good job dude
[Music]
good job dude
yeah
it's pretty good to see them play hide
and seek so they're all kind of like
different age levels uh taika's like
five is he five and a half yet no not
yet he's five
Leia's five Enzo is like two so it took
him a little bit more than 20 seconds
are you hiding now go go go go go tell
me your hiding spot yep always have good
hiding spots
oh that's smart oh they're never gonna
find you
that's really good that's a good spot
good yeah cover it up here I'll help you
here good job
oh they're never gonna find you
what are you looking for
taika you okay yeah
did you already find the ends already
hey you guys are using your Noggin
s
blanket okay
did you find taika check again
tank is good man really good guess who
he is
in our closet in our closet but behind a
lot of clothes
that's good that's really good I don't
know if you guys want to find them
though
[Music]
um
oh sorry I do that a lot you scared him
yeah I scare them all the time
no
smart checking on the hiding spots
that's smart
but just let you guys know typing
doesn't use the same hiding spots it's
really really good
looking down there that's good
[Music]
no no
yeah
he is very secretive
[Music]
so mama's gonna give them a clue right
now because this is Heidi's spot Studio
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I don't care
do you give up
do you give up this Taco win does take a
win don't give up don't give up
good job Enzo
where is he
[Music]
yeah the clothes no he's behind that
really good thank you you're doing a
good job don't make a move
[Music]
I'm telling you taika
is really really good at this game he's
gonna be a ninja look at his little
thumbs up give him a thumbs up
excuse me okay
ready
okay taika you win look
you're so good
like a win ding ding ding good job dude
don't count ends up
it's your turn to count come here
I'll be here okay count is the cutest oh
my God
good job
um
12 13 14.
16
19 20. go ready or not here he comes
[Music]
stop
good job
[Music]
good job good job looking you know every
place
[Music]
it's going to circle okay
[Music]
here's something you hear something
laughing
[Music]
no one there
okay
[Music]
did you hear that you hear that there's
something over there
good job that's really good I hear
something that way here's something that
way
you hear that
[Music]
good job
all right so they're just going to
continue to play hide and seek while we
babysit I think I'm having too much fun
because I really enjoyed this game too
thank you guys for following on this
such a long day actually but to see snow
clean the garage watch Jill literally do
nothing and now
you dancing look
that's ridiculous
CUNY
good night y'all